welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast
today's episode is a big q a catch-up in
which we answer questions about
hydration
cortisol nicotine warming up
re-sensitizing our muscles to
hypertrophy stimuli
why deadlifts are so fatiguing and much
more
we've also got a surprise announcement
we've got a special bonus episode coming
one week from today which is going to
feature the entire team
of mass research reviewers so greg and i
will be joined by dr eric helms and dr
mike zordos to discuss our favorite
studies from volume
4 of the mass research review which
covers the most notable exercise in
nutrition studies
that have come out in the year 2020 as
always thank you for listening
and we hope you enjoy the show
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast this is your one and only
full-time permanent host eric trexler
and today i'm joined by a special
temporary guest host
named greg knuckles greg how you doing
today i'm doing well how are you eric
i am doing well so uh before we get into
the hard-hitting content for today's
episode a couple announcements
today is going to be a pretty
straightforward q a episode we're
basically going to catch up on a bunch
of questions that have been coming in
from listeners
but the big news is we have a special
bonus episode coming next week
so we normally do episodes every other
week we're going to have back to back
episodes
next week the reason it's a very special
episode is because we're going to have
the whole mass crew
on the air uh talking about research so
it's going to be you
and me and it's going to be dr eric
helms dr mike zordos
all of the reviewers for the mass
research review that comes out monthly
and the reason we're doing it uh first
of all it's going to help us
raise some awareness about our big
annual charity sale that's coming up our
big black friday sale
which is going to contribute a lot of
proceeds toward the american foundation
for suicide prevention which obviously
is exciting
they do a lot of really important work
but it's also going to be a super
informative episode so we're going to go
through our favorite studies from the
past
year volume 4 of mass covered
all the most important research that
came out in the year 2020 a lot of
people are saying
best year on record uh so it's gonna be
fun to go back down memory lane
uh now if you're a mass subscriber
you probably know that that we do
roundtable audio discussions
every issue every month but this
episode's going to be different so
you know even if you've heard some of
the round table discussions about these
studies i think you're still going to
get a lot of new information from it
so it's going to be great we're gonna be
able to talk about a lot of really cool
research from the past year
we're gonna have some special guests and
i'm kind of treating it like an
open try out to see if i can finally
fill that permanent
uh co-host position so we'll see if if
maybe zordos or helms bring some
bring some energy to the table bring
some new perspectives but
after that we'll get back on the regular
regular schedule with episodes
every other week so before we get in
today's questions i want to sell out
really quickly
remember go to bulksupplements.com use
the code sbs
pod in all caps that'll get you a five
percent discount off of your order
and we've been having some good
discussions lately in the stronger by
science facebook group and the subreddit
so uh if you're not part of those groups
go ahead and join those
and join in on the fun also we send out
periodic research updates
via email so if you're not on our
newsletter email list be sure to get on
that as well
i'll leave the links for all three in
the description of today's episode
so normally we have a good news segment
sometimes there's good news in it
sometimes not today we have a
an objectively bad news segment followed
by a good news segment so
starting all the bad news for our
international listeners oregon
is a state in the united states and
in the u.s and it's not one of the good
ones it now well
as we'll see it's certainly not you know
and states kind of do their own thing
in america sometimes and then they'll
argue with the federal government it's
it's a lovely system we've got going on
here
but uh so oregon made some made some
headlines with the last election cycle
they
basically decriminalized small amounts
of like
all drugs and the the obvious bad news
component is that
the moral fabric of oregon all of the
family values
it is fully decayed um there are no
families there are no values in oregon
anymore which is a shame
however i'm call me an optimist i'm
always looking at the bright side
this is at least definitive proof of the
gateway theory
that marijuana is a gateway drug they
they decriminalize marijuana then they
legalized it and now
all of a sudden they decriminalized
everything else
it's total debauchery and you had a good
point that
based on the very strong slippery slope
logic
it might not be long before there's
actually government mandated
required drug use in oregon dude the the
friction coefficient on that
slope is minuscule at this point yeah
it's become a runaway train and i don't
know where it's going but i'm
i'm certainly comfortable speculating
and i'm sure it's going to
legally required uh use of really hard
drugs
i mean probably so i i can't conceive of
any other
potential outcome so that's the bad news
but we we also have
some good news um so going
down to florida gotta love florida
um actually before this uh
can i just boot in with the with a piece
of good news real quick
sure so uh after our next episode that's
coming out next week
we're actually going to be taking about
a month off because we're actually
moving to oregon
completely unrelated to the last segment
absolutely yeah
um okay now let's visit a good family
value state down in florida
never strange news coming out of florida
um
so so in florida there was an ironman
triathlon which is
a fairly typical occurrence but this is
a very special iron man
uh marathon because triathlon uh
chris nikitch uh made history in this
uh iron man triathlon as the first
person with down syndrome to complete
one
and so uh this is uh i mean
2.4 mile swim first of all i can't swim
so that's completely off the table 112
mile bike ride
absolutely not i don't even want to
drive 112 miles
in a car uh and then yeah
i don't know the exact order but on top
of that a 26.2 mile
marathon run uh you you've got the order
correct i'm pretty sure
cool so that's a lot of stuff man
that that's absolutely remarkable uh so
congrats to chris and then chris on
instagram people asked him
you know dude like reflect on this like
and he basically his message was uh
onward and upward time to
set a new and bigger goal for 2021 so
pretty badass you love to see it yeah
that's pretty cool
uh so i also have uh
you know what i i don't know that i can
call this a piece of good news or bad
news
uh it's more just uh an
indication of americans having
just on average completely pathological
sense of overconfidence uh so this
headline
uh cooking skills have improved so much
in 2020
that 40 think that they're ready to
compete on masterchef
uh so anyway that's that's a compelling
headline i would say
uh article starts more than 40 of
americans think their cooking skills
have improved
so much during the pandemic that they
could now compete on tv's
master chef according to a new survey
six and ten say their cooking skills
have improved
that is a that is a piece of good news i
would say like
getting better at cooking like maybe you
can cook yourself more healthy food at
home
uh you know cook good stuff for your
family friends people you care about
so like six and ten people saying that
their cooking skills have improved that
is good
um uh where's the funny part
uh yeah here it is
on average respondents say that they've
learned to cook eight new dishes in 2020
so just think about that for a second uh
they were essentially saying like look i
wasn't that good at cooking before
but prior to the pandemic literally the
only thing standing between
me and being a top chef quality chef
was [ __ ] eight new dishes uh which is
actually pretty wild but you're not even
you're not even getting
warmed up on the what's that place
called the the cheesecake factory
i mean you're on page one still
dude when uh when cheesecake factory
drops their menu on your table it's like
it's like a lost tolkien book yeah
if you aren't like i'm sure it's
regional to some extent if you're not
familiar with the cheesecake factory i
don't care where you live on the planet
google their menu i'm sure you can find
it
you're gonna think it's a joke yeah this
is probably only a slight exaggeration i
think it has
somewhere in the neighborhood of like
300 menu items
it looks like an ambitious project to
document
the entire range of food dishes that can
be made like
it is absolutely insane uh but i will be
honest that
that allegedly good news story kind of
bothers me a little bit because you know
people like you and me we've been
working on our cooking skills for
years like really honing our craft and
the fact that
these newbies think they can just roll
in and say oh yeah i can make mac and
cheese
it's like dude you guys have not earned
that like you haven't done anything
innovative
what are you doing with cottage cheese
probably nothing and
it's a little bit insulting to me i mean
i don't know if you feel the same way
no i agree wholeheartedly there are some
other good uh
some other good nuggets in here as well
so the article
continues the secret to perfection
quality ingredients
according to eight and ten respondents
uh
according to eight and ten respondents
who said that these are what uh
differentiate a great dish from a
mediocre dish
that's [ __ ] like it's
it's good if you can get your hands on
high quality ingredients and you can
afford it
but this just proves that these people
are shitty [ __ ] cooks because like
if you're decent at cooking
you can make like you know not great or
like middle of the road ingredients
into a very very good meal and like
having really high quality ingredients
does step it up a little bit
and you know depending on what you're
talking about it could make a big
difference
so you know if it's like a a usda prime
ribeye versus like a choice cut of
sirloin like
yeah sure that's gonna make a big
difference for like the steak you're
cooking
but i mean for most things like
skill in the kitchen matters so much
more than the quality of your
ingredients for for being able to cook
something that tastes good
yeah i think these people are largely
basing their answers on papa john's
pizza commercials
correct i think that's their school of
thought the other thing
like the last good nugget in here uh is
it also asks people um what
what dishes that they were like most
excited about trying to master in 2021
the number one thing on the list was
filet mignon which
i'm just gonna be elitist right now one
filet mignon is one of the most boring
cuts of beef that you can work with like
it's super ten
it's it's so one it's the easiest
cut to cook uh because like it's the
softest muscle on the cow
there's literally no way to cook a bad
fillet
so the fact that one they think that
they can go on masterchef but they
can't already cook an adequate filet
that's a problem
two it's just like it's so boring
because
you know if you go for like a good
tri-tip or a good skirt steak
or something like that it's gonna have a
lot of like
intense beefy flavor the filet mignon
doesn't taste like anything like it's
the most
it it's the cut of steak you give to
someone who doesn't actually like beef
uh so anyway i'm just gonna be an
elitist piece of [ __ ] about this but
just the fact that like
a lot of them don't already know how to
cook an adequate filet
and that's the thing that they're most
jazzed about
i'm just gonna go out on a limb and say
they're probably not ready for top chef
i just love imagining that the the
people responding to this are like
you know they learned how to cook like
macaroni and cheese
out of the box and then they're like for
this interview they're like
steven spielberg like let me tell you a
thing or two about making a film
you know they're just completely
overconfident
um all right so that's good stuff um i
guess some of that
loosely qualifies as good news sure um
all right so now we want to get on to
some q and a's here and uh i'm gonna go
ahead and kick things off
we we had a question uh from soyboy
iii uh and the question was
uh this individual heard on social media
mostly from the carnivore keto
and paleo crowds uh that pretty common
criticism of vegan diets
and basically just eating plants in
general is that they they have too many
anti-nutrients um and so the question is
is there any validity to this concept of
anti-nutrients and if
it is a legit concept to what degree
should people be worried about
anti-nutrients
in the diet um this is a good question
and you know this is not an area where
i've
spent a lot of time uh reading over the
years but
you know i i kind of refreshed my memory
took a look at some materials
um in the process of preparing to answer
this and
first first things first um you know
anti-nutrients are a real thing so it's
not like they're completely fake news
you may have heard in the past that a
lot of plant-based micronutrient sources
have
comparatively lower bio availability for
some nutrients
compared to animal-based sources and
anti-nutrients are not the only thing
playing a role there but they certainly
can play a role there so
anti-nutrients one of the reasons that
they come up a lot in nutrition is that
they do have the capacity to
block or disrupt the absorption of
certain nutrients
and so you start thinking about the food
matrix or the composition of a meal
and so you're thinking okay i'm trying
to get this nutrient from the meal but
i've got this anti-nutrient that could
be
interfering reducing or fully blocking
the absorption of the nutrient that i'm
trying to get
so these anti-nutrients are naturally
found in a lot of plants
and generally speaking they're compounds
in the plant
that are designed to protect the plant
from bacterial infections or being eaten
by
insects stuff like that so these
anti-nutrients typically have a
reasonably important role in the plant
itself
so some common anti-nutrients that
you'll see we'll talk about
phytates tannins lectins oxalates
there's a whole long list of things that
kind of fall under this umbrella
so these anti-nutrients they they are
real
but they are not nearly as scary or
worrisome
as a lot of people make them out to be
first and foremost there are a lot of
anti-nutrients that are found in foods
that are
objectively unequivocally healthy as
hell
like uh you know pick your favorite
i'm sure there are some people who would
equivocate about that
i mean pick your favorite vegetable
that's just absolutely
filled with with micronutrients top to
bottom
it's probably got an anti-nutrient
somewhere in there i mean i i saw a very
interesting
interview with uh uh what's this what's
his [ __ ] name paul saladino
oh okay uh on joseph rogan's
podcast uh talking about how
actually vegetables are bad well that
that's one school of thought
that's not my school of thought um
you know and this is this is one of
those things like
when you're starting with a premise from
anything nutrition related
the starting point shouldn't be okay
let's as a starting point throw out
everything we know about food
right like there's a whole lot of really
good evidence indicating that a lot of
vegetables
are really good and
trying to throw out all of that evidence
in one fell swoop is quite a tall task
and most who try
fail pretty hard
but anyway the the idea that you should
uh completely avoid foods containing
anti-nutrients
that's a bad plan there's a lot of
really really good
nutritious healthful foods that do
contain some amount of anti-nutrients
one of them by the way coffee coffee has
some anti-nutrients and
around this show we don't tolerate
people speaking poorly about coffee
so right off the bat put me in team
anti-nutrient if coffee
is in that category so you said tannins
as well right
yeah so that uh that rules out red wine
as well yeah doesn't it
yeah so i mean if you had to pick a camp
i know which team i'm on for sure you
know give me all the anti-nutrients
so you know there's all these foods that
are
awesome and or nutritious that happen to
contain some anti-nutrients
so of course the the solution is not
avoidance of anti-nutrients rather
you should generally be aware of them i
guess if you want if you want to
but but the important thing to keep in
mind is that a variety of different
cooking and processing methods
do impact anti-nutrients and will
diminish their ability to do these
nefarious things so
they'll be removed from from the food in
the process
of cooking and processing or they'll be
heavily impacted in terms of their
function upon
ingestion so you know you could try to
account for them
uh when you're looking at your your diet
and the way you would do that without
being
completely like without getting
it'd be really a pain in the ass to go
through and look at every little meal
you're having and
what are the nutrients what are the
anti-nutrients what's the balance here
i mean the best approach in my opinion
is
try to eat a broad diverse selection of
food sources with a variety of different
cooking and preparation methods
and it's probably going to be fine and
if you're really worried about it
especially if you're if you're really
high on the plant-based
uh food sources like for example if you
have no animal food sources whatsoever
and everything's plant-based
you know like i said a mixture of food
sources a mixture of
preparation methods and maybe you just
shoot for a little bit higher than the
recommended intake
you know the minimum recommended intake
for a lot of these different
micronutrients i mean
it just that alone it's pretty simple we
really don't have to worry too much
about anti-nutrients
you look at studies on vegetarians and
vegans who eat
diets that are either high in plant
foods or exclusively contain plant foods
we don't see you know a laundry list of
notable micronutrient deficiencies that
are actually attributable
to the presence of anti-nutrients there
might be some deficiencies if they just
don't eat a thing
that can that can be the case but we
really don't see a lot of
disastrous outcomes when we look at
diets that happen to have
a lot of anti-nutrients naturally
present so um
the best defense oh i should also
mention there's also
some researchers have suggested that
potentially the body
may be able to adapt a little bit to the
presence of anti-nutrients to increase
the absorption
of certain vitamins and minerals in the
gut um but but the the best
approach in my opinion is not to lose
any sleep over anti-nutrients i
i certainly i don't think anyone needs
to like
really take that deep a dive into their
diet and kind of suss out all the
details of where anti-nutrients are
finding their way in
it really just comes down to eating a
varied diet with plenty of food sources
uh different food combinations different
cooking methods
and you know one of the things i always
say about nutrition
is that weird diets can have weird
effects so like if your diet is like
90 raw broccoli yeah i mean
then you might want to take a look at
that right but if you're having a varied
selection of food sources with a variety
of different cooking and preparation
methods
anti-nutrients probably don't even
really need to enter your mind at all
and sometimes when i'm trying to like
re-center my perspective on a particular
nutrition topic
a question i ask myself is just like
if i never learned that this concept
existed
would i be completely fine and not
regret any of my food choices
and with anti-nutrients i think probably
the answer is like yeah if you never
learned that they existed
you'd be fine and you wouldn't have to
alter your nutrition choices in any way
so it's a thing that's real but it's not
something that should
occupy a substantial portion of your
mind and certainly nothing that you
should
lose sleep over okay moving on
um we've got a question for greg uh this
question is from
keen for ketamine uh probably out of
oregon yeah i was gonna say we already
have some oregonians writing in
all right um so here's the question if i
train for hypertrophy
and i want to re-sensitize my muscles to
growth
slash hypertrophy training because i've
been doing it for months and months and
months
should i do one of the two options
option one is just take one or two weeks
uh either completely off of training or
just do some like
really really really minimal training uh
option number two
should i do a longer mesocycle maybe
four to five weeks
but really shift up my really shift my
training style and do a lot more
strength
training rather than hypertrophy focused
training so
should i basically take some time off to
re-sensitize my muscles to growth or
should i just
shift my training style for a mesocycle
or a block of training
and one caveat the listener mentions
they are only worried
about resensitizing their muscles to
hypertrophy they don't really care
about strength or you know dropping
fatigue via deloading
or anything like that so greg have at it
oh man so
it's it's hard to say um so
really the best evidence we have of like
so-called uh re-sensitization to
training
uh comes from a couple papers by
agusawara and colleagues
where essentially what they did is they
they had a group of untrained
they had two groups of untrained lifters
um
and one of them just trained for one
study was 15 weeks another study was 21
weeks
uh or 24 i think it was 24 weeks
whatever a
reasonably long period of time one group
just trained for the entire
period consecutively and the other group
basically
uh was six weeks on three weeks off six
weeks on three weeks off six weeks on
three weeks off
etc uh and in that study
what they found is that over both
durations basically both groups
wound up in the same place so what they
saw is
basically like a logarithmic growth
curve
in the group of people who just kept
training continuously so faster gains at
first
and then you know still making gains at
the end but the rate of progress
slowed down considerably and in the
group going
six weeks on three weeks off basically
what they found is they'd get bigger for
six weeks they'd stop training for three
weeks lose some muscle
and then over the next six weeks uh they
would
gain muscle again at approximately the
same rate as the prior six weeks that
they were training
and then they take three weeks off again
they'd lose some muscle
train for six weeks you know gain a fair
bit more muscle
and basically what happened is those two
groups wound up in the same place
uh so you could look at that and say
well okay
theoretically if we extrapolate that out
further
and you know let's say this this study
ran a year
instead of six months if you kept seeing
basically the same rate of progress in
every
six week training block in the in the
group that was
periodically taking three weeks off if
you kept seeing a similar rate of
progress block to block to block to
block
and you kept seeing that kind of
logarithmic growth curve
in the group that trained continuously
eventually what you'd see
is the group that was taking three weeks
off from time to time
uh exceeding the group that was just
training continuously
um and so one we don't know if that's
the case
because you know study ended after six
months we don't know what would happen
after a year
uh and two you know that's uh
that's a relatively extreme intervention
i would say
um you know basically taking a third of
your time
not training uh and it was also an
untrained subject so anyway
like that those were certainly an
interesting pair of studies but i don't
know like i certainly don't think that
that's strong enough evidence
to base an entire training paradigm on
for well-trained lifters uh so
you know first off just acknowledge that
is the strongest evidence we have
for so-called resensitization
at least as far as it concerns kind of
like
longitudinal outcomes i guess so you
know of course if you don't go to the
gym
for two weeks or something like that and
then you
go get a really hard workout in you're
gonna be way way sorer than you would
have been if you
you know just kept training normally
hitting every muscle group
at least once a week multiple times per
week uh so
you know there there's some degree of
sensitization going on the question is
just like is that actually going to
help you get bigger um so the the
agusawa studies are really the only ones
kind of looking at that from a
longitudinal perspective
uh and i'd say their results are fairly
equivocal
um so anyway first off
i guess i was just kind of contesting
the premise a little bit uh
alkene for ketamine was asking how would
i re-sensitize my muscles
and so first off i just want to start by
saying i'm not sure that you need to and
i'm not
confident that doing so would actually
improve your rate of progress over the
long term uh but
okay let's assume it does let's let's
say i grant you the premise
um personally i think that
the like practical hypertrophy range
is large enough that you can basically
just set up your training
uh in kind of a linearly periodized way
such that you maybe start a training
cycle doing sets of
like 12 to 15 reps and then you know you
probably don't want to be working up to
like heavy doubles or triples for
hypertrophy
but you can probably work up to sets of
you know somewhere in the five to six
rep range like that's probably still
going to give you a pretty decent
hypertrophic stimulus so
over the period of several months work
up from you know basically sets of 15
down to about sets of 5
and then when you restart your cycle
you're jumping straight from sets of 5
to sets
of 15 and as someone who does a lot of
sets of 5
and not many sets of 15 i can [ __ ]
tell you
when you make that jump when you're
accustomed to sets of five
and you do a workout where you do 15s uh
you feel pretty goddamn sensitized to it
uh
you're you're gonna feel that workout
the next day so anyway i think that
that's like
a practical way um to
train in kind of like a logical
sequential manner
but then also occasionally have what
amounts to a fairly large shift in
training stimulus that
you know even though you're you you've
continued to train
it it will essentially amount to a
fairly novel stimulus when you go back
to it
after training with with heavier loads
and fewer reps
um so that's that's what i think i would
personally recommend
uh if the whole concept of of recent
re-sensitization uh is something that
you are
worried about all right
is this a question from someone named
water no
this is a series of this is two
questions
about from two people about water all
right so eric you have
two questions from two people about the
concept of water
the first one is water yes or no and i
would say yes
how do i water
are you gonna ask me the damn question
or not oh so okay
i'm sorry i thought that those were your
notes i wasn't
looking at this too hard okay number one
uh
i've heard that not being hydrated
enough has many implications for
performance
i've taken on the challenge of drinking
a gallon of water a day
and i'm urinating constantly how much
water do i really need
so question one drinking a lot pissing a
lot what do i do
question two in my searches on google
i found many articles saying it's better
to sip water
throughout the day as opposed to
chugging it
as it will absorb into my body more
effectively
is there any truth behind this also
i found myself always waking up in the
middle of the night
to go to the bathroom is this happening
because my body isn't better absorbing
the water throughout the day
is there any research to back up not
drinking water at least an hour or two
before going to bed
in terms of not waking up at night yeah
so we got two questions about water
um you know when i saw these i started
laying out an argument
in defense of the concept of water and
then i figured that's probably not
how we need to spend air time i mean so
water's good
um you know how does it affect
performance well
if you're excessively dehydrated your
performance starts to tank
it's a pretty straightforward
relationship
and then of course hydration goes far
beyond performance it's just a matter of
general health um
we need water uh we are largely made of
water uh water goes in water goes out
you can't explain that
and but the thing about hydration one of
the the key things that kind of links
both of these questions together is
when it comes to hydration of course we
need to make sure we have enough
water coming in per day but there's also
a very temporal
aspect to hydration so like a lot of
times you know
being in the bodybuilding world you'll
see the people who are like
yep gallon a day every day baby but it's
like
7 00 p.m and they've had three sips of
water and they're like well i'm gonna
get my gallon and it's like yeah but
you're gonna drink all of it at once
immediately piss out all of it wake up
twice during the middle of the night to
pee
and you spent most of your day
dehydrated right like that that's not a
good
not a good strategy so it's not just
about the total amount of water it's
about
getting hydrated when you wake up and
staying hydrated throughout the day that
that timing aspect
is pretty important for us to actually
enjoy the benefits
of being in in good hydration status so
first of all how much water per day the
uh the dri for water
is uh for males 3.7 liters and for
females 2.7 liters
what's that in freedom units though uh
about 3.7 quarts
because they're about the same thing
very cool so
so for males it's a little bit under a
gallon and for females a little under
three quarters of a gallon
um so uh the dri it's important to
recognize though
that's not just like hey here's the jug
you fill up at the beginning of the day
that's
that's total water intake total fluid
intake coming from
the water you drink other beverages you
drink and then also the water that's
present in a lot of foods
and so roughly speaking for the typical
diet whatever that means
uh about 20 of the water you're taking
in it's probably coming from food
and about 80 is probably coming from
beverages
um but you know when it comes to these
totals throughout the day
i think the question is you know what's
what's the downside of going a little
over
like virtually nothing right now if you
are drinking water to prove a point
you know like i mean if you're doing
like there's that uh unfortunately there
was that story there's like a radio
uh station doing like a competition i
think it's like hey who can drink the
most water and not like
no you know not like piss or whatever
they did not run that
by their lawyers no so somebody died uh
if memory serves
wait wait wait so they were trying to
not pee i think so i think it was like
something like that did their bladder
explode no it was uh
just depleted blood electrolyte levels
okay like i i heard that and i thought
hyponatremia like that's where my brain
immediately immediately went
but dude if people aren't exercising
intensely
i would just i would just strongly
anticipate that they're uh
like that they would be unable to stop
themselves from peeing
prior to consuming enough water to wind
up with hyponatremia
i don't you know i don't remember the
details of the contest i but
the general concept hyponatremia exists
if you're just like going out there to
see how much water can i possibly drink
without going crazy in a given day
that's not a good strategy but
if we're talking about like okay the dri
the dri is
you know 3.7 liters for a male
let's round it up to a gallon and let's
say well i've probably got some fluid
coming in from food but it fluctuates
day to day so i'll just drink a gallon
of water
a day that's fine you're going to have
you're not going to be regretting the
fact that you went just a touch above
the dri for water uh being a little bit
below
i mean you know if you're only one to
two percent dehydrated two to three
percent dehydrated
once you get close to two and beyond we
can start to see some of those uh
performance impairments depending on
what your training looks like so
if you're choosing between being a
little over and a little under i'd say a
little over
is a nice place to settle because at the
end of the day if you're just a little
bit over
your daily water needs you just get rid
of it you go to the bathroom
you pee it's kind of clear you're good
to go
so um the important thing like i
mentioned though is it's not just
total intake it's uh it's the temporal
aspect
so you want to get hydrated when you
wake up get out of bed
start working on your hydration for the
day so
the way i always phrase it is get
hydrated and stay hydrated
not just like hey let's chip away at
this gallon
um so not everybody needs to drink a
gallon that was just a really convenient
bodybuilding thing because like hey
those gallon jugs do exist and that's a
pretty convenient way to
put yourself a little bit above what you
need um
but you know wake up get some fluid in
uh
continue sipping throughout the day
there is there is um you know to get
back to the
the actual question itself that that
recommendation to sip throughout the day
it's not that the water is not absorbing
in other scenarios but it's just that
you know water is constantly
coming in going out and we want to make
sure that we have
consistent we want to maintain our
hydration status consistently
if we put all of our our hydration for
the day into a very brief window
we're going to pee out a lot of very
clear urine
and and then we're going to spend most
of the day dehydrated
if we're not mindfully uh maintaining
hydration status throughout the day so
you know three quarters of a gallon a
gallon
for most people that should be fine if
you're someone who's you know
losing a lot of sweat throughout the day
then then you bump that up a little bit
and make sure you got plenty of
electrolytes coming into the diet but
pretty simple stuff now fluid intake
before bed that's an interesting
topic because we do lose fluid
over the during the overnight fast and
so
uh you know the national sleep
foundation has stated that
going to bed even mildly dehydrated can
uh disrupt sleep a little bit in some
cases um
however nocturia the the
the act of waking up to go use the
restroom to wake up and pee in the
middle of the night
that can be an issue for a lot of people
and uh
obviously that's not ideal you don't
want to be waking up in the middle of
the night or multiple times throughout
the night which actually is not that
uncommon
uh sleep obviously has a really
important impact on
our ability to make body composition
improvements our ability to to train
effectively perform well
so sleep disruption is not a good thing
there's plenty of research on that so
if you are noticing that you are waking
up and using the
you know waking up and peeing once maybe
twice
or more you know multiple times
throughout the night then you might want
to consider
tapering your fluid intake in the in the
evening hours so
like i said wake up get hydrated stay
hydrated
but during those evening hours two three
hours before bed you might consider a
tapering down
your fluid intake uh just to make sure
that you're not going to have to wake up
in the middle of the night to use the
restroom so
it is a challenging balance to reach
there well and i'll just add that
that's especially a big deal uh if a
full
if a full moon is approaching or has
recently occurred
uh because basically like you know your
body's like the oceans the moon pulls on
it like the tides
yeah and you know it it will pull on
your bladder and
almost kind of like draw you out of bed
uh via tidal forces
um so yeah like especially watch fluid
intake around sleep
uh around the time of a full moon
yeah or other moons sure but uh yeah so
you've got a fine balance there right
you don't it's not serious by the way
it's not you go to bed uh you don't want
to be dehydrated but you also don't want
to be
excessively hydrated such that you're
going to wake up in the middle of the
night
and have to pee so uh there's a
what i would encourage you to do if
you're worried about it um
you know is is kind of keep a hydration
schedule
throughout the day and kind of figure
out what works for you
so obviously you know right upon waking
you want to get you know
a solid at least a couple cups of water
in you know get your hydration off
uh get it get started on the right foot
for that day
maintain hydration by having a schedule
of you know getting this many ounces
you know every one two three hours and
then figure out what kind of tapering
you have to do
uh toward the end of the day to be in a
spot where you're you're not going
to bed totally dehydrated but you're
also not waking up in the middle of the
night
and i will say this one of the things
that can be really helpful
for monitoring hydration throughout the
day is really simple
it's just a urine color chart it's not
perfect but
it usually does a pretty okay job and
basically
you can look at the color of your urine
and basically say okay these
shades are are pretty dehydrated in
general
these shades are pretty hydrated and
like i said it's not a perfect solution
but it's pretty easy
and it gives you a good indicator of
course there are other things that can
impact urine color so you'll have to
keep that in mind certain vitamins
can do that if you have rhabdo
that's gonna have a pretty pronounced
effect but you've got bigger problems to
worry about
um one time so i
i did my my dissertation on beetroot
juice
and so like one time i got really into
beats and i was eating beats a lot
because i was you know when you're
studying this stuff you kind of
naturally
get an interest you want to get like a
first-person experience
uh and i was on a date and i went to the
restroom
and i just was like hey um apparently
all my urine is red and i forgot that i
had
you know drastically increased my beat
intake and so i was like
i might have to end this date and go to
the hospital because i'm clearly
peeing a lot of blood um sorry for the
the visual there but
it wasn't it's just beets so if you are
consuming like a ton of beets or a ton
of highly concentrated beetroot juice
using urine color is going to be
difficult because it's it's not going to
be
it's not going to be on that chart it's
going to be pretty red
but but generally speaking for most
people wake up get hydrated stay
hydrated taper down toward the end of
the day if you need to
and just monitor urine color throughout
the day it should be a good strategy
so one thing i'll add uh if if waking up
in the middle of the night to pee
is a problem uh there is a nuclear
option
that's on the table uh so to speak so
i knew a guy who uh that was apparently
just like
a huge problem for him um so like
i would lift with this guy from time to
time and he would always just seem like
super tired constantly and i'd ask him
like i'm not gonna use his real name but
i'd be like hey man like
you seem really beat like is something
going on
is anything wrong you're like dude i
just can't sleep like
i'm waking up needing to pee like four
or five times
in the middle of the night every night
the first place my brain went is like
dude you might be diabetic
um anyway he wasn't diabetic like or
like a prostate issue right yeah
or something like that anyway apparently
all of that stuff had been checked out
he was fine uh he just was waking up
like four or five times in the night
every night he sounds so bad so anyway
uh he did something that i would never
have thought of
still doesn't seem like a great option
but worked well for him dude just got a
[ __ ] catheter oh no
uh anyway
i mean i i was i was in college i was
like 19 at the time so like
that seemed completely bizarre to me
that was the first time i'd ever
heard of a catheter so i was like what
the [ __ ] dude
um but anyway like literally overnight
uh his entire like energy level his vibe
his outlook on life completely changed
because he was able to sleep through the
night
oh man i i have so many questions but
we'll follow up off the air
about that okay
moving on we we've got a question from
lars do not
construe that as a recommendation god no
that is not a recommendation at all it
is it is
an anecdote that worked for one person
yeah man okay i have so many questions
we'll deal with that later um okay we've
got a question from lars here
why is dead lifting considered more
fatiguing
than squatting i've heard and read
several recommendations to be a little
bit more conservative with your deadlift
volume
compared to your squat volume but i
never really understood the reasoning
behind that
uh is it possible that deadlifting is
just super fun
so people you know can't stop once they
get going and they end up over training
what's
what's
going on here greg yeah so that's a good
question
um and i i think that there are
a couple things that could be going on
so first off
uh yeah i think it is definitely worth
pushing back
uh on just the blanket assumption that
deadlifts are
inherently more fatiguing than squatting
um
and in fact there's actually some
evidence suggesting that they aren't
so uh our good friend our mass
co-conspirator mike zordos
uh one of his i believe master students
uh actually researched this um like
basically looking at various measures of
fatigue after squat versus deadlift
training and basically they were
identical
didn't seem like deadlifts were
inherently more fatiguing than squats
um and another thing i'll note
is that um like so
a couple trends i've noticed is one uh
weight lifters can get away with doing
like pretty heavy clean pulls and snatch
pulls
uh pretty frequently like they can train
those
similarly to squats or at least like
more similarly than
power lifters trained squats and
deadlifts uh and i mean
clean pulls and snatch pulls are
essentially i'm sure there are some
weightlifting coaches who will get
really mad at me for saying this
but they're essentially just very very
strict deadlifts
um and and when they pull like that they
they seem to be able to
tolerate pretty high volumes and pretty
decent frequencies
uh and the other thing i've noticed is
that um
lifters who pull sumo tend to be able to
handle
higher volume and or higher frequency
deadlifts
than uh than people who pull
conventional you know not all cases at
all times but that's
that seems to be the general trend uh so
i think that there are
two potential things that could be going
on here one
is that uh so i think a non
a non-negligible factor which may not
necessarily
affect objective measures of performance
but might be affecting just
kind of subjectively how you feel after
a squat versus deadlift workout
is that deadlifts tear your hands up and
squats don't
so one of the things i've noticed in my
training is that when i deadlift with
straps i can handle higher volumes and
recover faster than when i don't
uh because like my hands don't get us
torn up and just like my finger flexors
and like
hand flexors don't get as fatigued uh
and i think that's potentially important
because you have just an enormous
density of sensory nerves in your hands
and fingers
uh so if if you if you've never looked
this up before a very cursed google
image search you can do
that i strongly recommend is just google
somatosensory homunculus and it's
essentially
a human body drawn to scale
based on sensory nerve density
um and so like uh basically like
your hands are very very big your lips
are very big
uh most of the things on and around your
head are very big
uh most homunculi that i've seen are
are like safe for work but when they
actually draw the whole thing like
sexual organs are absolutely enormous
uh but yeah it's based on like the the
density of sensory nerves
uh and so you have a [ __ ] load in your
hands um
and so i think that like when your hands
are super fatigued or when they get
torn up just from the knurling digging
into them i think that basically like
anytime you're doing anything throughout
the day that involves your hands which
you know people use their hands a lot
i've heard uh that's like a defining
feature of primates
uh you're just getting like constant
knock noxious
feedback from your hands to your central
nervous system
uh and again like i i don't think that
that would maybe necessarily affect
many objective measures of performance
other than like hand grip strength
but i do think it might just contribute
to generally feeling kind of shitty
after deadlift workouts
uh so i think that that's a
non-negligible factor in play
and another thing that that i think is
probably more important
and that um probably at least to some
degree
explains one why people seem to be able
to pull sumo more often
than conventional and why weight lifters
can get away with
relatively high volumes and frequencies
of uh
of snatch and clean pulls uh is
basically you can just get away with
more spinal flexion in the deadlift than
the squat
especially if you're going pretty hard
at it uh so
you know basically if you're squatting
and especially if you're high bar
squatting
although this does apply to low bar as
well once your spine starts flexing
you're dead in the water
uh because like now like
essentially your your chest and
shoulders are falling relative to your
hips
uh you know if your spine is flexing and
your hips are staying more or less in
the same place
the bar might start like shifting up
on your shoulders and at that point
you're done like you're gonna lose the
bar over your head
um i've seen a handful of lifters
uh in my lifting and coaching career who
um like somewhat frequently flexed their
spine a fair amount in the squat and
still
completed the lift uh and and i know a
few more people who
who basically can get away with that
when they're like really really grinding
a lift out
but for the most part like 95 97 99
of people like you you start
experiencing
substantial spinal flexion in the squat
and you're done the lift's over
uh whereas like you can grind a deadlift
with
a pretty fair amount of spinal flexion
and like you know
you just get close to lockout you
re-extend your spine
you're fine you know um and so
i i don't have
what one might call science or data to
back this up
but my my experience both as a lifter
and a coach
is that like if your spinal extensors
get
really really fatigued that makes
literally everything else really really
fatigued like once you get that
that deep deep low back fatigue
uh shit's [ __ ] for a while
not in like a a danger like injury way
uh but you know you're just gonna feel
like [ __ ] and your performance is gonna
be bad
uh until your low back is not as
fatigued anymore
uh and and basically i just think that
like conventional
not crazy strict deadlifts are more
susceptible to bring that
about than sumo deadlifts squats
clean pull snatch pulls um so anyway i
think that those are
are the main factors in play and another
one that i'd add to the list
as well uh is i think that there's some
degree of path dependency
in at play here so um
most of the popular novice programs out
there like i don't know what percentage
of uh of lifters initially started their
training career with
uh starting strength or strong lifts but
you know i think is a relatively large
percentage uh and you know those
programs have people squatting heavy
three times a week
uh and i'm not sure about strong lifts
but in the case of starting strength
like
the deadlift training is one set of five
deadlifts
once a week so it's it's a very low
deadlift training and so
uh like when you're moving on to
something else essentially like
you're you're you should be pretty
robust
against squatting induced stress because
you've been doing a lot of hard squats
and you just don't do that many hard
deadlifts and so i think that
people kind of move on to other programs
from a starting point
of being able to tolerate more squat
training than deadlift training
and then they basically think that
that's just like an inherent state of
things
like you know my experience has always
been
that i can do more squat training than
deadlift training therefore deadlifts
are
inherently more fatiguing whereas you
know in an alternate universe where
those ratios were reversed you know
maybe if you're
pulling heavy three times a week and
only doing one set of five squats once a
week
you know people might believe otherwise
like squats are inherently more
fatiguing if i try to ramp up my squad
volume [ __ ] goes to hell
but i can handle way more deadlifting
like i don't think that that would be
completely implausible
um you know and people who uh
who get into like powerlifting
bodybuilding whatever
from a sports background there aren't
that many like high school sports teams
that are doing a bunch of heavy
deadlifts either like
they're generally doing a fair amount of
squats and then the pulling is mostly
power cleans
uh which again is isn't going to toughen
up your
posterior chain to the same degree that
heavy deadlifts will so i i think that
there might also be a an element of path
dependency where
you know people basically always train
deadlifts with lower volume
therefore it takes less total volume to
fatigue them
uh but not not to not due to like an
inherent characteristic of the exercise
itself
you know they've just done less of it so
they're less
uh less robust against stress that it
induces
um so anyway
those are my general thoughts i think
maybe a combination of those things
contribute
maybe i'm completely off base but those
uh those are my hot takes on the subject
all right good stuff so my next question
is from justin kirk
and this question i believe was actually
posted a really long time ago
and we just like didn't get to it but i
think it's become a little bit more
timely uh so justin asked
do either of you two know uh of any
available evidence
on the altitude masks that people use in
the gym so you remember
i it's probably like two years ago that
those were were really making the rounds
but
you know people were wearing the
altitude masks and the whole idea was
that they simulate altitude
you wear them when you're training and
you look like bane
um but uh but but the the questioner uh
the
listener who asked this question says it
seems like if you're not living at
altitude
those adaptations that you might get
from the mask would would probably fade
so let me start by saying this as
someone who
enjoys physiology and exercise
physiology
altitude altitude exposure is pretty
awesome
like it is a cool thing so when you're
at altitude
the partial pressure of oxygen is lower
and you know a lot of things change at
altitude but probably the the hallmark
adaptation the thing that people
talk most frequently about is when
you're at altitude for a while
we adapt by increasing epo levels which
increases red blood cell content and
ultimately
enhances the oxygen carrying capacity of
blood
now here's the catch uh i think you can
make a really good argument that the
best
option when it comes to leveraging
altitude exposure for training purposes
i think the best option is living
high so living at altitude spending most
of your day
and evening at altitude but actually
training
at a lower altitude so so that's a
common thing that a lot of endurance
athletes do and
these adaptations associated with uh
altitude
exposure are most directly relevant to
endurance type exercise but a lot of
people
that do high level endurance exercise
they will you know when they're doing
their their main like training
leading into competition they'll stay up
high on a mountain and like sleep there
and
lit generally live up there and then
drive down
do their training and then go back up to
their you know their cottage up there
and what's really nice about that that
option of
living high and training low is you can
generally
exist at altitude and get some of those
adaptations throughout the day of having
that low partial pressure of oxygen
but you know training at altitude can be
difficult because
you know the fact that during that early
adaptation process it's kind of hard to
get the oxygen where you're trying to
get it
that could theoretically impair your
training volume so
it's a nice little mix of both and there
you know there's some papers
arguing about how you should balance
that altitude exposure and whether you
should train at altitude or train
down low but but i i think you can make
a strong case that
a pretty ideal scenario is altitude
exposure most the day
and then training at a more you know
closer to sea level
now when we talk about these elevation
masks um
if we accept the premise that they work
which i don't
but if we do accept that premise it's
kind of the worst of both worlds right
because you're not
wearing your altitude mask 23 hours a
day and then saying all right i'm going
to pop this off
i mean maybe you're not you know i'm
going to you know
lose the mask and go to my workout for
the day it's inverted
it's basically i'm going to spend 23
hours a day
doing my thing with my face fully
unmasked
and then i'm going to put it on for an
hour and go to the gym
and that that's really not an ideal
scenario even if this was
replicating altitude but you know there
is published
you know exercise science literature on
um
these altitude simulating masks and
there's just there's just no benefit i
wouldn't even call them altitude
simulating masks
masks that because they are marketed as
altitude
yeah related because i mean really
that's the rub they don't
they don't simulate altitude no altitude
the partial pressure
of the air you breathe through a mask is
literally the same partial pressure as
the air outside the mask like it's it's
not
it's not doing altitude [ __ ] it's not
and
and so there have been some studies
looking at some you know different
training protocols
with or without these masks no benefits
for vo2
max peak power output or a variety of
other aerobic
and anaerobic outcomes generally here's
a
something that did change uh rpe
perceived exertion was generally
increased by about two points
at the same workload so when you're
doing work that would typically be an
rpe
you know six out of ten throw on the
mask congratulations now it's an eight
out of ten but you're not performing any
better
like so it just made exercise suck
and did not enhance adaptations um
now i have seen people making small like
very specific arguments for like well
maybe it has a training effect on the
muscles
involved with ventilation um
maybe but it takes a very specific
scenario for that to really impact
training
like no one's there are very few people
for which ventilatory
uh muscles are their limiting factor for
for exercise performance
yeah like that that could be a factor
for like ultra endurance
athletes uh you know you're breathing
pretty hard for
hours and hours and hours ventilatory
muscles can fatigue
uh it's it's actually like a
somewhat important thing for competitive
swimmers
um just because like there is the
pressure of the water pushing in on your
rib cage so it
takes more effort for your rib cage to
expand when you're trying to breathe
so so ventilatory muscle fatigue can
actually be a problem for a
non-negligible amount of uh
of competitive swimmers and the other
situation and here's really the irony
uh the masks don't simulate altitude
but they may not be terrible for
training
when you're planning on doing something
at altitude um so you know if you're
planning on
hiking a relatively high mountain
respirator
ventilatory muscle fatigue and even
sometimes
ventilatory muscle strains can occur
um basically when you're when you're
operating at
quite high altitudes like we're not
talking like
6000 meters we're talking like 10 000
meters plus
uh you can't actually deal with like
pretty significant
ventilatory muscle fatigue in situations
like that
uh so even though the altitude mask
doesn't simulate altitude and
it may not be a terrible thing to like
prepare your ventilatory muscles for
altitude um for very high altitude yeah
like
like i mean if you're if you're not
mountaineering that's not relevant to
you
um but yeah like those are situations
where
you know not just so-called altitude
masks but just like ventilatory muscle
training in general could be beneficial
and i'll note you don't have to buy a
mask you can literally just breathe
through a straw like that's that's how
ventilatory muscle training is generally
done uh
and just like forcefully breathing
through
smaller and smaller straws is uh is
generally how it's done
but you know you can buy a mask if you
want to yeah
but you know for most listeners who
maybe you know do a 5 or a 10k now and
then or
mostly lift weights you know the
ventilatory or the
um i don't even know what to call them
the masks that purport to simulate
altitude probably not
an important part of your tool kit uh
but this
like i said this question has become if
we kind of go a little bit on a tangent
a little bit more relevant because
obviously
a lot of gyms across the world now
require that you wear some type of mask
and a lot of people have been asking
questions or speculating about how that
might
impact their ability to train right so
these are very different from a mask
that is basically
designed to make it harder to breathe
like that's the opposite of what they're
trying to do
but uh there is some published research
looking at
exercise performed when wearing the
types of masks that that you might
potentially wear to to minimize uh
you know covid risk and so there was a
crossover study with
12 healthy males and they had three
different conditions so
it was either wearing like a pretty
heavy duty n95
like that's a serious mask or wearing a
surgical mask
or wearing no mask and an important
thing to keep in mind is in this study
like when we when we measure ventilatory
gases
in an exercise science lab we also have
to put on a mask
to capture those gases so if anything
this study's probably
overestimating that mask effect because
we're talking about
a mask on top of a mask there so they're
breathing through the mask
and into the ventilatory mask that's
capturing those gases
uh which probably wouldn't be
particularly fun
but you look perplexed i i'm just i'm
just trying to
picture that in my mind they have a
picture of it in the study well
i'm gonna go look at that yeah so um
anyway looking at the results here uh
the n95 mask
you know just taking a very uh cursory
glance at the results
the n95 mask did
result in lower maximal power
outcomes during a maximal vo2 max
testing
also a lower vo2 max value was achieved
during those tests compared to no mask
and the results kind of went in order so
like
you know in terms of max power achieved
and vo2 max achieved
no mask was ideal and then the surgical
mask was a little bit worse than no mask
and then the n95
was worse than the surgical mask um
however uh there there's a a little bit
of an exchange there's a letter to the
editor written
uh in response to this article and uh
you know some scientists looked over the
results and they're like you know i'm
i think you guys might be discounting uh
just the the impact of overall
discomfort and perceived exertion here
because
in in the conditions where they are
wearing the surgical mask and even more
so when they are wearing the n95
it wasn't just that they achieved lower
power output and lower vo2 max but it
was that
it looked like they were just
terminating the maximal test a little
bit earlier so
they weren't achieving the same like
blood lactate levels some of those
indicators of a maximal effort
didn't look quite as pronounced in those
masked conditions
and in this study to the author's credit
they did look at
a variety of different discomfort
related
subjective assessments and
when they looked at the overall
discomfort score
with no mask it was 2.8 out of 10. with
the surgical mask it was 5.2
out of 10 and then with the with the n95
it was actually 7 out of 10
for discomfort and so the authors of
this letter to the editor
basically suggest you know it's a nice
study
good findings but we we do wonder how
much that
general discomfort caused these
participants to prematurely terminate
their vo2 max test
which is why we're seeing lower power
output and lower
uh maximal vo2 achieved so
it when it comes to actually turning
this into practical
application takeaways the one thing is
that
for people who don't have any
ventilation related
pathologies or medical conditions it
doesn't look
like there's much to worry about when it
comes to mask wearing during exercise
and especially like you know most people
their typical exercise is not a maximal
vo2 test with
with a with a second mask on top of
their mask
um but there there does seem to be uh
for many people a notable
um effect in terms of discomfort so you
might find that you're generally less
comfortable with the mask when training
you might find that your rpe
is a little bit higher and of course as
the results of that study actually show
it's probably going to vary based on the
actual mask you're wearing so
n95 versus surgical mask versus a cloth
mask there's probably
a great deal of variation there and it
probably also depends on the
exercise modality and intensity that
you're training with
um so like i said now if you've got uh
asthma or an actual medical condition
that does impact ventilation
it might be worth a closer look and you
know i'm not an expert on that so i'm
going to leave that
like i'm not going to touch it but but
for healthy people that don't have any
issues with
with ventilation and breathing these
these results seem to indicate you know
for the type of training most of our
listeners do probably not a huge deal
outside of that discomfort effect so
we've got another question for greg here
by land ho the question is a lot of
bodybuilders
use nicotine gum or other nicotine
products during a contest prep
to suppress appetite and increase energy
have you guys ever used these products
and what are the benefits and risks
of using nicotine products in this way
have i ever used nicotine products yes
i am i'm using a nicotine product right
now
i chew a fair amount of nicotine gum and
have for uh for a decent bit
um and if you were to ask me why
it's for a couple reasons uh one
sometimes i don't sleep much and it uh
it helps keep me going through the day
uh when i do sleep
um i still use it because it helps me
focus better and
just generally makes me feel good i also
use a lot of caffeine
i'm a fan of uppers that's my vice
[ __ ] sue me
uh but anyway yeah uh so
nicotine and uh how that might
um you know just affect
the things that people might be
interested in you know
as it comes to lifting uh dieting
etc so nicotine is an appetite
suppressant
um the you know
the drawback to that is uh one of the
things that's like pretty commonly seen
when uh smokers quit
smoking is they uh often gain quite a
bit of weight because you're
you're basically like so i you you do
habituate
to the appetite suppressing effects of
nicotine and then
when you remove it you will then have a
greater appetite and a desire to eat
more
uh so you know if you're planning on
using it for appetite suppression
um anticipate using that as kind of like
a short term crutch
so if you were dieting and you wanted to
use nicotine as an appetite suppressant
i'd recommend probably only using that
for like
the last maybe week or two of your cut
because if you're planning like a four
month cut
and you're a month into it and you're
already using nicotine as an appetite
suppressant
by the time you're actually getting
quite lean that nicotine is not doing
[ __ ] for you anymore
um and so uh
anyway yeah if you're gonna use it as an
appetite suppressant
um plan on the front end for that to be
like a short-term thing and
and make sure you're using it
strategically uh because
if you use it a fair amount all the time
it ceases to be an appetite suppressant
it basically just keeps your appetite
from
being elevated um
so that's the first thing second uh this
question
didn't ask about exercise but
you know that might be worth touching on
just in general
there was a systematic review by johnson
and colleagues
title was nicotine effects on exercise
performance
and physiological responses in nicotine
naive
individuals a systematic review and so
it essentially found that
there are some plausible mechanisms by
which
one might assume nicotine would be
beneficial for exercise performance
but basically all of the actual like
placebo-controlled research to this
point finds that it doesn't
really do anything uh at least if it
if it does have an effect uh it's not
large enough to be reliably detectable
um
so i i mean like again this is just me
personally this
this is my experience with nicotine um
i find that it it might uh kind of
sort of help improve motivation and
maybe decrease perceived effort to some
degree
um which is is largely one of the things
that caffeine helps with as well
uh caffeine on the other hand is
actually a direct ergogenic like it
it does um significantly
increase strength and power performance
nicotine doesn't seem to
um i personally use both caffeine
and nicotine before workouts again i
like uppers
sue me uh but yeah like the
as far as like exercise stuff goes
caffeine and nicotine do similar stuff
but except nicotine isn't an ergogenic
and caffeine is
and as far as like reducing perceived
exertion goes caffeine's better at that
than nicotine
so you know unless you just have like
an extreme caffeine tolerance if
caffeine still does anything for you
uh caffeine's probably a better
pre-workout stimulant than nicotine is
on balance and this
this question also asked about risks
so my understanding
is that well so
first off there's not just a ton of
research
on uh non-tobacco
well and these days there's also someone
vaping
but most of the research looking at the
health risks
associated with nicotine are
specifically looking at tobacco products
and there's
obviously a ton of stuff in tobacco
products other than
just nicotine and there's also
now some research on vaping but you know
the
the potential health risks associated
with vaping seem to be
largely related to either like additives
that find their way into the
into the vape liquid uh contaminants
or just risks associated with kind of
the
you know inhaling hot gas that has
recently been combusted
um obviously that's not in play if
you're just chewing gum
so uh yeah i i haven't actually been
able to
round up that much uh
like long-term safety data on
just like nicotine itself either in like
a gum form or patch form or something
like that
lozenges uh like
basically everything i've seen seems to
say like
it's a heck of a lot better than smoking
and then the next question is like
yeah but you know what is it like
by itself uh and there doesn't seem to
be that much research
out there what i've seen seems to
suggest that it's uh
its safety profile is not that
dissimilar to pretty much any other
stimulant
like if you have high blood pressure
it's a stimulant it's going to
exacerbate high blood pressure
if you have if you have a heart
condition
that might be exacerbated by
coronary hypertension definitely not a
good idea to use pretty much any
stimulant
um yeah otherwise like it basically just
seems to be a stimulant and
and have a safety profile comparable to
other stimulants
um so anyway yeah
if uh i think my general recommendation
is if you don't need to use stimulants
uh
or like you don't just want to use them
because
you like how they make you feel which is
the camp i'm in
uh you're probably better off not using
stimulants if you can help it
and if you're going to use one caffeine
seems to probably be
your best choice especially for exercise
stuff because it is an ergogenic whereas
nicotine is not and also you can consume
caffeine in the form of coffee which has
a lot of
of health promoting effects independent
of the caffeine there's there's a lot of
good stuff in coffee
um so yeah that's uh
those are my general thoughts on
nicotine the other thing that i that i
would add i suppose
um is if you're if you're working
relatively late into the night
and you do need stimulants to help keep
you awake and help keep you focused
in a situation like that nicotine
might be i'm not going to say advisable
because
that might get me sued it's worth i
suppose considering
so nicotine has a considerably shorter
half-life than caffeine does
so if i'm you know if i'm finishing up
work
right before i'm about to get ready for
bed uh and i've
you know and i most recently put in a
piece of nicotine gum
like an hour and a half two hours prior
to getting in bed
i find that it doesn't really affect my
ability to fall asleep stay asleep wake
up feeling refreshed
whereas you know if if i used
my last relatively large dose of
caffeine two hours before i was getting
in bed
i'd be [ __ ] that would be a shitty
night of sleep
um so yeah that's another
reason that i use nicotine i try to
basically stop using all stimulants
or at least like severely cut back on
them once my work day is done
um but you know if my work day is a
budding
when i'm about to go to sleep nicotine
seems to
to be more conducive to or not more
conducive
less anti-conducive to sleep uh than
caffeine is just because
you're you're dealing with a much
shorter half-life uh
so yeah those are my general thoughts
about
and experiences with nicotine yeah
we've talked about this before outside
of the show
uh i've never tried nicotine um
i have a very addictive personality i'm
already addicted to caffeine and i just
feel like
why add more to the mix you know like
like how you mentioned like if you don't
absolutely need it
probably best not to even venture into
it like that's kind of where i'm at it's
like
caffeine's fine i like coffee and if i
start using it i'm going to start using
it a lot i just know
how i'm wired um no i i agree
wholeheartedly like
one of the questions i'm asked the most
is like well
like are you afraid you're going to get
addicted and it's like
i'm not afraid of it because i
definitely am addicted yeah
like yeah that is 100 the case
i'm also very addicted to caffeine
another thing that i'll that i'll say
and this is like purely anecdotal
um if i so
if if i do take like a true weekend day
um
i'll generally try to like push as late
into the day as possible
without using stimulants just you know
for for
uh for kind of like a tolerance break
and also
just kind of to see how far gone i am
and one of the things one of the things
that's that's
very very apparent to me uh is like i
need
caffeine first thing upon waking no
matter how much i slept the night before
if i don't within about two hours of
waking up i'm gonna find myself with a
splitting headache
um like in so like you know
two options if i say popped in a piece
of nicotine gum right when i woke up and
didn't consume caffeine
i'd still be in a very bad spot like
without the caffeine i get the headaches
i get withdrawal symptoms not good
uh if i if i consume caffeine when i
first wake up
um i don't feel the need
to consume nicotine like i i think i
feel
a little bit less mentally sharp but i
don't
really seem to experience any notable
withdrawal symptoms
um so yeah like it helps me focus
and i like how it makes me feel but i
would say on like
a relative level of addictedness like i
at least like physiologically i'm
considerably more addicted to caffeine
than nicotine
but i'm definitely addicted to both yeah
i think mentally for me one of the
things that makes
my caffeine addiction easier to manage
is just the fact that there's
not like any kind of stigma surrounding
it like i was brainwashed as a child by
dare it's like dude nicotine that's bad
news
but like if you talk about like oh i'm
addicted to caffeine people are like
yeah me too
check out my funny t-shirt about it you
know it's like a completely different
thing
uh which is not uh necessarily a logical
way to view it but like for me i'm just
like yeah if i have to choose one
crippling addiction i feel like
caffeine's the most palatable
um that's just not a social pressure i
feel
yeah like when when people find out like
i can see it in their eyes
and i'm not saying there's anything
wrong with it but no i i
wasn't interpreting it that way like but
but i can tell when some people find out
like some people judge me for it
i just don't care yeah no it's not that
i would ever judge somebody
for it it's that i'm uncomfortable with
me knowing i'm addicted to a thing
that isn't caffeine and it's completely
arbitrary i admit it's it's not a
logical
uh perspective but like such is the
nature of brainwashing
dude change of subject since you
mentioned dare
uh so previously on the podcast uh i've
mentioned that one of my favorite
podcasts
is called you're wrong about yeah
strongly recommend it very entertaining
uh they had uh an episode on dare and
how
uh completely ineffective it is i
strongly recommend people check it out
it's a very good episode
uh but one of the things that they
mentioned um which
i guess i hadn't really thought about
because it's one of those things that
like i grew up with dare for people
outside the us that don't know what dare
is
it stands for drug abuse resistance
education uh and basically like someone
would come into the school
generally a cop like it was a cop for us
i think that's just kind of how
how it worked um and you know they
basically say like look if you do drugs
uh
you're gonna [ __ ] die i personally
will arrest you and send you to prison
forever
um all of your teeth are gonna fall out
like
everyone who has ever done any drug uh
goes to prison for 20 years and dies on
the street like it was
like a 100 fear-based thing
with a slight educational component
about like the negative effects of
every drug in existence but the thing is
uh it it backfired really badly and like
one of the reasons it backfired is
basically
you have a cop going into the school and
saying like
hey uh here are
all of the drugs that are out there that
you're
you know nothing about these drugs those
weren't ideas floating around in your
head
i'm just going to inform you about every
street drug in existence
so if you're the type of person who who
might get curious about drugs
i am going to satisfy that curiosity and
let you know what is out there that you
might want to experiment with
uh and two you know when i'm telling you
how drug dealers might approach you
and might solicit you to buy drugs i am
simultaneously telling you where you
might be able to find
drug dealers and how they might interact
with you
if you're the type of person who wants
to feel out like oh is this person a
drug dealer can i ask them
to buy drugs or like you know is this a
[ __ ] cop or someone who's going to
snitch on me
uh and so like it's basic it's it's an
educational program that is essentially
informing people
what drugs are out there and how to
obtain them uh
to some degree it's a brochure and then
a script
for like okay here's how you get it and
then also like it uh
it would like shake people's confidence
in authority figures like surrounding
the topic of drugs because
it was just like 100 a fear campaign
it's like
uh you know we we joke about the dangers
of marijuana use but like
you know if we were a dare officer all
of the things we've said about
marijuana on this podcast we probably
would be saying to like fifth graders
completely unironically
uh and so you know you plant those ideas
in kids heads
and then you know they get to middle
school and some people start doing drugs
and then they realize like
wait a second like that's still my buddy
they haven't changed that much
i feel like officer so and so lied to me
yeah and so uh you know that it would
basically just like backfire from that
perspective because
you know once people learn that shit's
not as scary as
as they were told they're just like ah
maybe it's not that bad
at all maybe i should try some stuff and
they just told me
what i should try and where i can get it
so yeah anyway our dare officer was such
a
was such a heavy chain smoker that
um like they would administer the
education
if memory serves largely in like an
assembly format
like the whole school gets in the
gymnasium and then he kind of grabs the
podium and it kind of
warns us about the dangers of tobacco
and other things and dude he'd be like
directly outside the gymnasium with like
with like
three cigarettes in his mouth at once
just to try to get him through the 45
minute presentation
your dare program covered tobacco oh
yeah i think so
whoa so ours um
so you were in north carolina yeah like
i grew up in north carolina
uh tobacco road yeah we were we were 30
minutes down the road from the
second largest cigarette producer in the
world
rj reynolds represent baby um
but yeah like dude so our r said uh
like they were warning us against the
dangers of drugs
and tobacco like tobacco was appended as
something that's like not really a drug
um and and the messaging was basically
just like
uh alcohol that'll [ __ ] kill you weed
that'll [ __ ] kill you cocaine that'll
[ __ ] kill ya
cigarettes yeah not great if you use
them use them responsibly
like that so i i think they may have uh
have they may have geographically
tailored
the uh the cigarette portion of dare
yeah yeah i mean
we were in ohio so we didn't have any of
that
lobbying going on at the local level
um okay so moving on i've got a question
here i got two questions actually
about cortisol so um cortisol comes up a
lot
um you know people are very interested
in it because there's a lot of
people talking about how it affects you
know muscle breakdown and fat storage so
two questions here
number one is there an actual
evidence-based connection between
cortisol
and fat storage especially belly fat or
is this just kind of a myth
question number two what's the state of
research on cortisol's actual impact
on fat accumulation seems like a lot of
internet outlets
uh are telling us that cortisol causes
belly fat
but digging deeper on it i couldn't
really find much evidence
so cortisol not a myth
it is a hormone it exists um and
there's a good side and a bad side of
cortisol so
the good side of cortisol is that we
need it it plays a really important role
in the acute stress
response it helps mobilize energy
substrates when we've got that nice
fight-or-flight response
cortisol has important functions in the
body and if you didn't have cortisol
you'd be in bad shape that'd be a
problem
the bad side of cortisol is that too
much can be bad especially in a chronic
perspective so cortisol's effects
it is anabolic in the liver but has
catabolic effects
elsewhere including skeletal muscle
and it also can have some divergent
effects
on adipose tissue so in some instances
it can cause lipolysis in other
instances it can cause
lipogenesis but you know a really easy
way to look at
the effects of cortisol is in an extreme
example
and and i think probably the the most
extreme example that's commonly known
would be cushing's syndrome so this is a
medical condition in which you have
chronically
very high cortisol levels and uh
it does present uh clinically
with with a particular pattern of body
composition characteristics so
an individual with cushing's syndrome
will often present with
fairly thin extremities a lot of that is
because you know like i said
generally catabolic outside of the liver
so
it can be difficult to put on muscle
mass in the extremities with chronically
you know pathological you know uh
chronically high cortisol that is
pathological in nature and outside of
the typical reference range
now uh individuals with cushing's
syndrome will also typically present
medically
with uh greater adiposity in the face
the neck
and the trunk and a lot of times
there will be abdominal obesity present
along with
uh insulin resistance high blood
pressure and dyslipidemia
so cushing's syndrome uh is kind of a
glimpse at what happens when there is
really high chronically elevated levels
of cortisol it's kind of
an exaggerated look at mechanistically
what does cortisol do
in terms of body fat accumulation
and effects on skeletal muscle mass so
in terms of what cortisol does that's
pretty straightforward
and i think cushing's syndrome gives us
a pretty straightforward glimpse into
that
but it's really important to recognize
that that is a very extreme example so
when people talk about
cortisol in the fitness space you know
they'll talk about
the small fluctuations within the normal
range that occur in response to
a heavy training bout or an isolated
instance of
you know kind of like panic or you know
psychological stressors
and in the fitness space the practical
impact of cortisol
i think it's blown out of proportion
because the acute fluctuations that
occur within typical ranges
really are not a big deal so if you've
got
acute cortisol elevations that are
related to exercise or psychological
stressors
there's no action needed that's normal
ups and downs and there's also a diurnal
variation where throughout the day we'll
see cortisol values
go up and go down so in the
overwhelming huge proportion of
instances
there's just absolutely no action needed
when it comes to your cortisol levels
now if you have chronically high
cortisol levels due to
pretty severe and pretty constant stress
then there probably is some action
needed but
you're not intervening on the cortisol
you're you're intervening on the
the source of the stressor you know so
if you are just
chronically living in a state
approximating terror
you do want
[Laughter]
you do want to act upon that but
it's it's about stress management or as
much as it's feasible removing those
stressors from your life
um so having chronically high cortisol
due to
very severe constant stress is a bad
thing but you want to intervene on the
actual stress not the cortisol it's not
like oh
i'm still just like living you know in a
state of terror all day every day
but good thing i got this cortisol
supplement like that that's not the
order of operations there
and then finally if you have chronically
high or low
cortisol levels that are outside of the
typical range due to a medical condition
again that's something that you will
want to intervene on but it's not by
getting like a cortisol supplement you
got to get in touch with an
endocrinologist
there are medical conditions that cause
uh
you know fluctuations in cortisol that
are outside of the typical reference
range either
suppression of cortisol or extreme
elevation of cortisol
and those should not be ignored uh they
should you know you should
seek help with those types of clinical
conditions but you're getting that from
a doctor and an endocrinologist
not a fitness website right so
uh the short version is cortisol
absolutely has
the potential to very meaningfully
impact body composition fat storage
uh muscle tissue accretion however
actually intervening upon that or doing
anything about it is pretty much
outside of the realm of fitness the
stuff we can actually
uh you know the little fluctuations day
to day that we
impact with our activities there's
really no action needed there but if
we're talking about
really chronic psychological stress we
need to work on
the actual stressor and stress
management strategies not the cortisol
level
and again if if you've got something
that's influencing
the actual production of cortisol either
increasing or decreasing
that's the type of thing you want to
speak to a doctor about
okay a question for greg this is by
unnamed player on reddit and the
question is
i've noticed that barbell medicine has
recently
been talking a lot about the minimalist
warm-up so the idea is that people
are wasting too much time with
activation and mobility and so on before
their workouts
and that they should pretty much keep it
simple so what are your general feelings
on this and the concept of
just using a barbell to warm up for
lifting
yeah i mean i i think it's fine uh
if you can do it you know like if if
that's something that works well for you
go for it so i i do think
i i do think that there are probably a
fair amount of people who
do too much warm-up stuff uh
in you know like it's not necessarily
bad to do a bunch of warm-up stuff but
you you do reach a point of diminishing
returns like it is possible
to do so much that you know but by the
end of your very elaborate warm-up
routine you're kind of wasting your time
you're doing
30 minutes of warm-up drills when you
could have gotten away with 10.
um so you know like that that is
certainly
something that's possible um so i think
that there are a couple things to keep
in mind
one is just kind of a cost-benefit
analysis if you spend
a little bit too much time warming up
doing activation drills doing mobility
work etc
what's again cost you um what it could
theoretically cost you is if you're
going to the gym on a relatively tight
schedule you know let's say you have an
hour to work out and you're doing 30
minutes of warm-up
activation mobility work etc uh you
basically just cut in half
the time that you can spend actually
training so like there is a real cost
there whereas
if you could get away with a 5-10 minute
warm-up you can
come relatively close to doubling the
effective amount of time you have to
work out so that that could be pretty
meaningful
uh if you're someone who has a more open
schedule and
you know your your the actual lifting
part of your workout is going to take an
hour
and you're going to have that hour and
it's basically just like do i spend an
hour and 10 minutes in the gym with 10
minutes of warm up and an hour of
lifting
or an hour and a half in the gym with 30
minutes of warm up and an hour of
lifting
uh you know and you have that time and
that's time you don't mind spending then
there there's essentially no cost to
doing a lot of warm-ups and so
you know in that case who cares like if
you like doing it if it makes you feel
good go for it
um so i i think in a general sense
um you know it's it's not necessarily a
terrible
idea to see if you can get away with
doing
with spending less time warming up and
preparing to train
uh you know just because that is kind of
perpetual
time savings if if you find out you can
shorten your warm up by
10 15 20 minutes uh but at the same time
i i don't think that
i don't think you should necessarily
approach it with a goal
of like you know the the
least amount of warm-ups i can do and
still have a somewhat adequate workout
is the appropriate and correct amount of
warming up to do
like i think that some people can take
minimalism too far
to where it becomes an end unto itself
uh and the way i see it like the the
purpose of warming up is to prepare
yourself
for the workout to come and so if you're
doing
more than you need to to prepare
yourself for the workout to come
yeah you're probably wasting a little
bit of time if you're doing
less then you need to to prepare
yourself for the workout and you're
you know maybe elevating your risk to
some degree because
you're not just adequately warming up
the muscles you're about to train
uh you know maybe you do have some
mobility stuff that you do need to work
on to get into the
to the positions you need to get into
for the exercises you're gonna do
you know then that is that is costing
you something like it may be hindering
your performance it may be increasing
your your risk of injury to some degree
um
so yeah i wouldn't necessarily push for
the shortest most minimalistic most
abbreviated warm-up
possible for its own sake i think the
basic process
is just ask yourself like hey you know
what's the first thing i'm going to do
when i go to the gym and start warming
up
like does that benefit me you know and
you can troubleshoot it you know like
each little step in your warm-up just
leave it out one workout
and see how your workout goes do you
still feel fine
okay maybe you can leave it out okay now
now
maybe you've gone from five things in
your warm up to four things
okay kick another thing out do you still
feel fine
does does your workout still go well
cool you can
you can leave that thing out okay now
you're down to three things in your warm
up
okay now you boot another thing out how
does your workout feel
not quite as good okay maybe leave that
thing in and try booting out one of the
other three things that are left
you know basically just use that
troubleshooting process
and once you find a spot where you are
doing
maybe fewer warm-ups than you were
before but you're still feeling just as
good
you know that's great you're still
performing just as well and you're
saving a little bit of time
um but i i wouldn't necessarily
recommend
you know going from a lot of warm-up
stuff to
just warming up with the bar uh you know
basically going from 100 to zero just
just for its own sake um
you know because again uh just
just based on the cost benefit analysis
like i i think the
the the cost of
warming up less than you could benefit
from is probably greater than the cost
of
you know wasting five or ten minutes of
warming up a little bit too much
uh but yeah those are those are my
general thoughts just
just kind of some things to keep in mind
as you approach the subject
good stuff i totally agree um okay we've
got one more question
for today's episode um and this one is
for me
it's by paul and this is a good one
because it's a good excuse to talk about
the general chaos
associated with bodybuilding so paul
asks are there any expected anomalies
in natural bodybuilders blood tests you
know
especially during high volume
overreaching phases or during contest
prep dieting are we seeing any impacts
on things like
red blood cells white blood cells
testosterone iron
etc and so first of all
a really important thing for for all
listeners even if they're not
bodybuilders is that lifters in general
do tend to have slightly different uh
blood profiles
than people who don't lift right so uh
it's
not uncommon to see elevated creatinine
in lifters especially those who eat a
lot of meat and take a lot of creatine
and have a bunch of muscle mass
and so that ties into our recent
conversation about
uh the estimated glomerular filtration
rate
stumbled over it a little bit pretty
smooth but yeah
gfr we talked about how that's in many
cases a creatine based
estimate or creatinine based estimate
and uh yeah so that can be
very much skewed uh in lifters and also
it can
fluctuate a decent amount from day to
day uh
lifters we will also see elevated uh
creatine kinase
and there are some studies where you
know
they do you know heavy eccentric
training
uh and yeah if you didn't know that
individual had done heavy eccentric
training and you looked at their
creatinine or their creatine kinase
levels
you'd be panicked and you should be like
because if there's not
training there there's a major medical
condition occurring or
that recently occurred like it's not
good
um yeah if isn't it generally like you
only see those numbers
if either someone just exercised really
hard or has recently had a heart attack
usually i think there are some cancers
that can also elevate creatine kinase if
memory serves but definitely the heart
attack
and heavy intense exercise so
yeah if you just like roll into a blood
test with no
context and you know you just did a
really heavy workout the night before
your creatine kindness is going to get
some attention
uh other things we often see elevated in
lifters and it's really easy to find
these because just
look at any paper on acute muscle damage
and recovery
and say what were the outcome measures
right so like uh
lactate dehydrogenase myoglobin blood
urea nitrogen can be elevated liver
enzymes can be elevated
there's a lot of stuff from just lifting
alone that can be elevated
um when it comes to overreaching you
know a lot of the early
overreaching and over training papers
would look at the cortisol to
testosterone ratio
uh i'm certainly not indicating that
that's a driver
of overreaching over training or even a
perfect diagnostic test
but it is a metric that does when when
you really push somebody and
intentionally try
to to make them overreach or over train
it's not uncommon to see a higher ratio
of cortisol to testosterone
now when it comes to it's also not
uncommon to see
uh elevated levels of pro-inflammatory
cytokines
yeah uh so like interleukin-6
interleukin-1 beta and tumor necrosis
factor alpha
are are the three that kind of are most
reliably
elevated uh those i don't think
generally show up on just kind of like
baseline drug tests uh or blood tests i
mean
yeah um so yeah i mean like those
those might be things that if those are
things you're interested in you'd
probably have to request them special
yeah and then you could probably add
c-reactive protein to that list as well
yeah that's another one that comes up a
lot now when it comes to bodybuilders
uh prepping there's even more chaos
associated with that so we recently just
this year published a case study uh brad
schoenfeld was a lead author
uh and there was a bunch of a bunch of
my buddies on the paper
me and tinsley and uh campbell and a
whole bunch of others i
don't want to list everybody i'll leave
people off cody hahn was on it was one
of our stronger by science coaches
but yeah it was a really nice group of
people to work with but
we did look at some some blood test
outcomes and
saw you know the pretty common stuff we
saw low testosterone low thyroid hormone
uh white blood cells did drop at a
certain point in prep so
seeing those different blood
abnormalities especially when it comes
to the sex hormones and thyroid hormone
uh pretty common in prep and there's
been a a decent amount of research on
this from the uh the crew over
at the university of yavaskula so uh
utah uh yuha homie yuha atienen
um yeah their their whole group
really fun group i love them i visited
the university a couple years ago
and dude it's just folks that love
bodybuilding and are damn good at
science
like everybody you talk to walking down
the hallways is just freaking smart
and they want to talk to you about like
arnold schwarzenegger and stuff
it it really is a wonderful place
so they do a lot of great work on
bodybuilding
and in the last few years they've
published stuff
looking at some of these effects of you
know what changes during prep
beyond the beyond the basic stuff beyond
you know strength and body composition
so
uh they did a study uh in female
competitors
uh looking they did look at body comp
but they also looked at some
hormones and they found that over the
course of prep they saw reductions in
leptin
t3 thyroid hormone testosterone
estradiol
and of course increased incidence of
menstrual cycle irregularities which is
not the least bit surprising but the
good news was that stuff generally
reverted
in the three to four months following
competition
they did another study in a similar
population
female physique athletes and they looked
at a variety of different
biomarkers related to inflammation and
immune sys the immune system
and you can i'll put the link in the
show notes you can look at all the
specific biomarkers they looked at it's
quite an involved study but generally
speaking over the course of prep they
saw
attenuated markers of systemic
inflammation
but also markers indicating some
immunosuppression
so you know looking through a a
particular blood test
if you're looking at things related to
inflammation or immunosuppression
some of those can be altered over the
course of contest prep
they published another paper probably
with the same cohort i would assume
same number of participants female
physique athletes
and uh you know they found beneficial
changes in
in a number of biomarkers related to
cardio metabolic health
so um what that tells us is basically
whatever blood test you're looking at if
you've got a physique athlete who's in
prep
whether the blood test is related to the
immune system
inflammation cardio metabolic risk
endocrine profile muscle damage
kidney function liver function there's
gonna be abnormalities in there
and you have to consider what which of
these abnormalities
is related to just being a person who
lifts with a lot of muscle mass
what's related to their dietary intakes
what's related to the enormous caloric
deficit
and the low body fat so yeah i mean
probably probably grounds for like a
completely separate certification there
like how to actually interpret a
bodybuilder's blood tests when they're
like deep into prep and i i do remember
one funny anecdote uh i had a buddy who
was training a very very very
elite like ifbb olympia level
bodybuilder
and was going like rep for rep with them
in the gym but my buddy was not
an olympia level ifbb bodybuilder
and uh so so my buddy sent me a
some blood tests and he was like hey my
doctor's a little bit concerned what do
you think and i was like dude
this is just a disaster like you gotta
take some plates off the bar like but
like everything
kidney function liver and none of it was
acutely concerning
but it was more just like dude like
you're clearly not
hanging in these workouts this is not a
good thing like
just for for your well-being like i'm
not worried about your kid in your liver
but
like a little bit worried about your
your general
state of mind right now how are you
feeling but uh
his buddies just like coasting through
the off-season
and he's like unironically approaching
every workout as if it's like
a battle in a protracted war yeah
and in that scenario i actually think
that's probably the right mindset
um now one other thing so in the
question that mentioned
like iron specifically but on the
nutrition side
a bodybuilder deep into prep you're
probably
gonna see i would i'm speculating here
but probably a number of
maybe not nutrient deficiencies but at
least insufficiencies i mean when you're
talking about a person who's
training that hard which can elevate
losses of certain nutrients
and you're also talking about latent
prep low calorie intake
often reduced diversity of food sources
a lot of times people are like listen
with my macros i've got like four foods
on the table right
so it's very common to see people really
whittle down the list of foods they eat
and get to a pretty small list of foods
so i wouldn't be
surprised to see a number of like sub
clinical insufficiencies for a bunch of
different micronutrients but
i would probably not expect anything to
be too pressing and of course
we have to remember this is a short
window
in the individual's life right i mean
we're talking about
hopefully a short period of time and
then they're going to recover and get
back to a more typical dietary intake
but
for someone who you know is doing the i
compete
spring and fall and spring and fall and
spring and fall
then that might be worth a closer look
okay uh to play us out uh this is
something you sent me this morning
i didn't tell you i was actually going
to include this in the show but
i'm flattered yeah this is an
interesting thing that you sent for once
is is this why you wanted me to to come
on as a special guest for this episode
exactly yeah for once you sent me
something that wasn't
just mind-numbingly stupid
so this was a very recent study by
ebersole and colleagues and
it's called many labs five testing
pre-data collection peer review
as an intervention to increase
replicability
and i took a quick look at it seemed
very interesting i mean
please feel free to jump in and correct
me if i'm wrong on any of this
a quick interpretation we've talked in
the past
about replication in science and there's
a big project to try to replicate a lot
of
findings in the field of psychology that
fell a little bit short of replicating a
lot of the effect sizes were drastically
smaller
when they tried to replicate these
findings that were originally published
and so what these authors speculated was
like okay
you know maybe some of these replication
attempts had some limitations when you
look at the methods that just
didn't do a good job of replicating the
original study
or just didn't elicit the exact
phenomenon they were trying to get at
so let's be charitable maybe the failure
to replicate
is a failure of the protocol that was
used to try to replicate these original
findings so
the idea was before we collect data on
these replication attempts
let's actually get some some experts in
the area to peer review the methods
we're going to use
like take a look at what we plan to do
and then we'll actually do it
you know incorporating their feedback so
i i think it was mostly like the authors
of the original studies
oh okay yeah like i think when when mini
labs one came out
uh they're you know they they basically
said like hey we looked at all of these
various
seminal effects in the field of
psychology uh a lot of them aren't
replicating
uh and i think some of the authors that
published the original work
like kind of took it personally yeah um
because they
the the the people behind
uh the mini lab studies aren't alleging
fraud like they're not alleging that
anyone is doing anything bad just
basically saying like look
there's probably a fair amount of false
positives in the literature
uh but like you know people have their
egos and whatnot and so i think like a
fair amount of the
of the authors of the original studies
basically said like
well look you said you were trying to do
a direct replication of my study but
like
here's like one or two tiny details
that differed between what i did and
what your replication attempt did
and like if you would have done things
exactly like i did
my effect definitely would have
replicated and so i think this is
basically just
uh like the center for open science
folks just like
calling their bluff and saying like fine
what do you want me to do yeah like
come on board like help us
ensure that we are running the perfect
experiment
that would replicate your effect if your
effect is
replicable yeah it does say here like
commenters with the first round
basically said that the
uh the reason that they failed to
replicate the original effects
like oh you didn't adhere to uh expert
review you use low power tests you like
you didn't reliably and faithfully
replicate this because of methodological
reasons
uh and so yeah they basically
were like okay fine like let's get
feedback let's you know
hedge your bets as much as you'd like
and and let's remove
any possible questions about statistical
power issues
by having [ __ ] 1300 subjects on
average
for uh for all of the effects they're
testing yeah so they say we
we picked 10 studies revised the
replication protocols got formal peer
review
prior to conducting these replication
attempts
and administered the replication
attempts using these revised protocols
across multiple laboratories so like
they were really trying to
do this like as thoroughly as you
possibly can and basically they found
that
following this kind of updated
pre-registered plan for data collection
the revised protocols that they used in
this study the effect sizes were very
similar to the replication attempts
previously that the original authors
were a little bit
annoyed by i think if anything it was
actually a bit worse
so if memory serves uh
and and i i think actually i think this
might be the difference i think in this
study basically they were looking at
at a subset of the effects that they
were attempting to replicate in mini
labs one
but i i do remember mini labs one like
fairly vividly and the the mean effect
size of the replication attempts
was about half of the mean effect size
of
of the original papers uh and in this
one
the the mean effect size for the
replication attempts
was basically like a fifth the effect
size of the original papers
yeah so at the very least uh
it didn't go it didn't go the way the
original authors were probably hoping
right it'd be like you think at least
like okay well it got a little bit
closer to what we found
if anything looks like the opposite so
this is uh you know it's psychology
research so it's not directly related to
like topics that we look into a lot but
because we've talked about
uh the importance of replication we've
talked about the kind of open science
movement in the past
i figured it was a good thing to play us
out because it's a little bit off topic
but
you know i think this kind of highlights
why
open science is important why
replication attempts are important
and to a lesser extent kind of tying it
all together like
why it's fun to do something like mass
you know because
i i think a lot of people on the surface
would be like well just
i don't know like read the abstract see
what it says and if you're really
skeptical read the full
text but when you're trying to really
apply
research findings and contextualize them
and get a good
working understanding of a body of
literature you have to
look out for this kind of stuff and say
okay well here's a study that has a
finding but
what do similar studies find has have
there been replication attempts if so
what do those replication attempts look
like you know trying to piece together a
body of literature
and cut through the false positives the
false negatives
uh you know the what's the term like the
first finders effect
so that's one of the ones that's really
tricky
because you know i'm approximating
the definition but basically for for any
particular given topic
the most likely scenario is that the
first studies to get published in that
area are going to be the ones that find
something pretty noteworthy
yeah right like pretty exciting and kind
of flashy and it's not because anybody's
doing
anything wrong it's kind of it's kind of
secondary to human nature right like
we start doing research on this topic
and if if we try something new and
something's kind of boring and stupid we
might be like uh whatever like
i didn't invest much in that study
anyway like who cares we'll just leave
it
but if you find something cool and
alarming and like really flashy you're
like dude let's rush this to the presses
this is cool
and so you know when you're trying to
evaluate
especially a brand new body of
literature there's so much context that
goes into trying to
to really
make practical replications or practical
applications and takeaways from
okay we've got one awesome study on this
that has this really flashy effect
and then you know one similar study with
nothing what do we do with that
yeah well and i mean one of the other
problems with with that as well
is like not only does the first finder
effect exist
but just like the way the way that
sciences
tend to work is like there's almost like
a patronage system
where uh like if you're writing about a
particular phenomenon
you are expected to cite
and discuss uh the the researchers
and the paper that like first discovered
and communicated whatever that
phenomenon is and so
essentially the the first finder effect
uh the outcome of it is generally like
the first
finding in a body of literature tends to
overestimate the effect size
and then you know just based on how
expectations around citing quote unquote
seminal findings
works is like that paper is the paper
in that area of the literature that is
going to get cited and discussed the
most
and so it uh it it basically like sets
an unrealistic baseline not just simply
from existing
but from being the the study that like
basically everything else is compared
against
uh and so it becomes like normalized as
like
you know this wasn't just the first
finding this is the most
normal finding because it's the finding
that people are going to be exposed to
the most
yeah like if you think about uh the
topic of progressive overload
like if like if i say progressive
overload the first name that comes to
people's minds is delorme
because like he's the guy who did that
like in the 40s with army people
um and i mean like dude there's so many
[ __ ] resistance training studies
now uh there are
literally thousands of names that you
could associate with the concept of
progressive overload
uh but i mean if you're writing a
narrative review paper about progressive
overload like
first thing you're going to do is you're
going to you're going to say the name
delorme and you're going to talk about a
study
um and actually come to think about it
or come to think of it i don't know what
the effect magnitude was
in the delorme study so that that might
not be the best uh
the the best example of what i'm talking
about but like you get what i'm saying
like that that is
that is the researcher and the paper
that comes to mind first
when you think progressive overload and
so if if there's some other like
sub area of inquiry where
you know there's there's someone else
who found an effect first
and like their their name gets brought
up all the time their [ __ ] gets cited
constantly
if they overestimated the effect size in
their seminal paper which they probably
did
that that is basically then the effect
size that people
come to anticipate moving forward until
there's enough studies to like
meta-analyze and
realize like oh wait the actual effect
here is quite a bit smaller
yeah i mean what's really cool about the
these replication attempts
in psychology is they really reinforce
the idea that
research is cool and important and
valuable but
we can't take any single study at face
value and assume that that
effect size we see in one study is just
absolutely the one true effect size that
we can expect moving forward and
whenever you look at published
literature you really got to dig in
and think you know about the the context
of the study the context of how
publishing works like as we're talking
about with that first finders effect
there's a lot to consider there so i'm
looking forward to our next episode one
week from today we're going to have the
whole mass crew on
greg obviously is coming back we're
going to have eric helms mike zordos
we're going to talk about all of our
favorite studies
from volume 4 of mass basically covering
the entire year
of 2020 so we hope that you'll join us a
week from today
and we will be back soon
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button
at the top if you want to join in on the
stronger buy science podcast
conversation
be sure to check out our facebook group
and our subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits
be sure to check with a qualified health
care professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode
of the stronger by science podcast
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you